How often do you use disposable cups?
Did you know that using disposable products,...
...which are most often made from paper, plastic, cotton, or polystyrene foam...
...are not good for the environment?
I understand a lot of people use disposable goods because it's convenient.
You can just throw them away after using them...
...and you don't need to wash and reuse them.
But not only are the disposables harmful for the environment,...
...but they are also not good for your health.
Have you heard about the term "environmental hormones"?
Yes, let's see if I'm right about it.
Isn't environmental hormones a term that refers to chemical substances present in the environment...
...that disrupt a certain function of humans?
Well, I did hear in the news that we get those environmental hormones from disposable products...
...and that's why I always bring my own cup,...
...so I don't waste or have to use disposable cups.
But the thing is, I see Koreans using more disposable products compared to the country where I'm from.
I guess Korean people are more mobile,...
...and live in a state of "urgency".
I like what you are doing to help reduce the number of disposable cups wasted.
I think people should carry around their own cups, or other utensils,...
...especially at their workplace.